[MUSIC PLAYING]
IMOGEN HEAP: Hi, guys, very
nice to be here on the stage,
happy to share whatever
you want to ask me,
and I actually spent a bit of
time up in the creative labs
one day and just saw
some amazing things.
So if it's anyone in here
that I might have met,
hello again because I saw
lots of kind of music,
cool little music
apps they were making.
And yeah, it was good.
BEN ARTHUR: Nice.
So folks here in the
audience might know you
from songs that were licensed
for the "OC," or Zach Braff's
"Garden State," or your
collaborations with Taylor
Swift, or Ariana
Grande, or they might
know about your performative
technology endeavor
in the Mi.Mu gloves.
They might have heard
about Creative Passport.
They might also have heard about
you doing the "Harry Potter
Cursed Child" soundtrack.
All of these things
are out there
in the world, which seems
breathtaking in their scope.
How do you think about yourself
when you introduce yourself
at the allegorical party?
How do you consider yourself?
What's your identity?
IMOGEN HEAP: I don't know.
I just say, I enjoy
anything that kind of
is around the intersection
of music and tech.
That's what I say.
I don't go, like,
I'm a musician.
I'm a producer.
I'm a performer.
I'm an engineer.
Hello, I've won some Grammys.
[LAUGHTER]
I just go, I'm into
music and tech.
BEN ARTHUR: I'm
into music and tech.
OK.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
that's what I say.
BEN ARTHUR: So there's the
big umbrella that you--
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: --consider.
One of the things that
I've heard you reference
a couple of times, and it
seems almost contradictory
to my image of you,
is only do what
you can see in the headlights.
Can you talk about
what that means to you?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
I would love to.
Before the days of
Google search engine,
we had a thing called Yahoo.
And one day, I was in the
studio, and I was making--
BEN ARTHUR: We'll
bleep that out.
IMOGEN HEAP: Why?
It is a nice story.
And so I was there, kind
of going round and round
in circles trying
to finish this song.
So I am in my studio.
That's the first time
I recorded a studio--
recorded an album on my own, so
I was in the studio constantly,
all by myself, for a year, and
so it does send you a bit mad.
And because I didn't have an
A and R man, or anyone that
would come in and go,
oh, that's really good,
or oh, you should turn
some more cowbell up,
or whatever they say, I
was going round and round.
And so I couldn't
finish his song,
so I went onto
the search engine,
and I just said, how
do you write songs?
And I found this article
about this writer, novelist,
who had written
this little blog,
and it said in it, only do what
you can see in the headlights.
And what she meant
was, if in the song
you can see that there's a
hi-hat that needs fixing,
or you're trying
to finish a lyric,
and you can see the colors of
his eyes, then just do that.
Just write that bit, and
just keep chipping away.
And eventually, you will see
the full path ahead of you,
and you'll see
all the landscape.
But it's that kind, oh,
I've got so much to do.
I've got so much to do,
and it's overwhelming,
and you can't breathe, and
then you just remember, well,
do what you can see now.
Just do that.
Don't see, don't do all
that complicated stuff
that's far away.
You know you have to
get to it eventually,
but you can't see it just
yet, so just do that.
So that's what I mean.
Yeah, and I use that a
lot in everything from,
like, how do I
look after my child
this morning when I've got
to get to this interview,
and I've got--?
You know, I just
say, do what you
see in the headlights, which
is make sure she has breakfast,
and that's just, yeah,
it seems to be how I--
BEN ARTHUR: You are
supposed to feed them.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, I hear--
BEN ARTHUR: I'm a father--
IMOGEN HEAP: I do hear that.
BEN ARTHUR: --so I know.
IMOGEN HEAP: For six
months, I didn't feed her.
BEN ARTHUR: Every meal--
you're not allowed
to skip even one.
IMOGEN HEAP: No.
[LAUGHTER]
No, it's true.
BEN ARTHUR: It's
very strict rules.
So one of the many things
that you've juggled
is the "Harry Potter
Cursed Child" soundtrack.
We're going to see a quick video
introducing that album, which
has just been released.
[MUSIC - IMOGEN HEAP, "GODRIC'S
HOLLOW"]
IMOGEN HEAP: That is a bit of
the play, which is on Broadway,
which is wonderful.
Yeah, for about four years
ago, I got a call from a friend
called Steven Hoggett, who
is a movement director,
and he used to have this group
called The Frantic Assembly.
And when I released--
well, just after I released
a song, an album, called
"Speak for Yourself,"
which is the same album that
I couldn't finish that song,
and I released it by
myself with my own label
and eventually
licensed it to Sony
because I couldn't do
with all the mail orders.
But before that, I got this call
from this guy, Steven Hoggett
back then, like 20, 15
years ago, and he's like--
are these annoying
you, by the way?
[RATTLING SOUND]
[LAUGHTER]
Or should I take them off?
Are they present?
No?
Because they're
really annoying me.
Anyway, so yeah, he was like,
I love this album "Speak
for Yourself."
Could I-- I want to put it in
this play that I'm working on,
and there's going to be
people dancing around to it.
And I was like, OK,
that sounds really good,
and I didn't ask
him for payment.
And I was just like,
that sounds good.
Yeah, OK, here you
go, and I tweaked
some things I made it a bit
longer, and that kind of stuff.
And then it went into this
play, and it was really great,
and I loved it.
It was the first time I'd
seen live dance to my music,
and I really enjoyed it, but
I didn't ask for payment.
But if I had been signed to
a major label at the time,
they would've been
like, uh, yes, we're
going to spend a whole year
discussing how much she
should get for
this, and then you
won't be able to use it anyway.
Aha.
So I basically-- yeah,
it was really great.
And then we made friends,
and we kept in touch,
and then he did all
these amazing things.
And then the next-- not the next
call, but a call four years ago
was him saying, hi, Imogen,
or Immy, as he calls me,
working on this play,
and I can't really
tell you what it's
about, but they
love your music
and all this stuff
because I did all this
weird orchestral stuff
and a capella, strange
stuff for an accompaniment
for an old silent movie.
And nobody ever gets to hear
that stuff, but he loves me,
and he loves all
of my music, and he
knows it all really well.
And so he was putting
all these random bits
in there, which hardly anyone's
heard, and it felt really good.
And he was like, I
think they really just
want you to make the music.
And I was like, who is it?
And he said, I can't
tell you, but it's
about a boy with a scar.
And I was like--
[LAUGHTER]
--OK, that's a bit
of a give away.
And so I looked up online,
and I saw his name connected
to this creative
team who'd already
announced they're doing a play.
And then I was like,
that's exciting.
So then, yeah, I
met up with Sonia,
who's-- she's the producer,
and they offered me the job.
And yeah, life took a
very different turn.
Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: What was your
relationship to the Harry
Potter universe before that?
IMOGEN HEAP: Thin,
quite distant.
I really don't like
reading very much.
I mean, that's not true.
I like the information
that's in the book.
I just don't like the process
of actually reading it,
and I've never enjoyed that.
My dad thinks that if
it wasn't down to him
kind of showing
me, going through,
he thinks I'm
dyslexic, and maybe
because I really struggle
getting the words in my head.
Maybe that's why I
like making my own.
So anyway, so yeah, so that's
how it ended up in there, and--
BEN ARTHUR: Fascinating,
and if I can ask,
for those of us who were much,
much deeper into that universe,
can we fanboy and fangirl
out for a second and ask,
did you hang out
with JK Rowling?
Did she invite you
to her house, which
I assume is a magical
castle that you can only
access by a unicorn or a
magical boat or something?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, I did meet
the lady herself a few times.
Yeah, she was on
set quite a lot,
and yeah, she's was
very nice to me.
She says-- she actually, I
think, when I first met her,
she did this to me.
And I was like--
no, she's very happy because
I discovered that they really
wanted somebody British,
a composer that's British
and that was a woman.
BEN ARTHUR: So I was
never in the running--
IMOGEN HEAP: There's
not that many you can--
BEN ARTHUR: --really at all.
IMOGEN HEAP: I think also
with the help of Steven,
and the fact that the director
and him are best buddies,
it all it all helped.
BEN ARTHUR: So can you tell
us about the creative process?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: Because as
I've heard you describe it,
sort of it's a creative process
within a creative process
because they're working
on their own thing.
IMOGEN HEAP: Is that your phone?
BEN ARTHUR: It's
really awful, isn't it.
IMOGEN HEAP: Roger!
BEN ARTHUR: Embarrassing.
Ben.
IMOGEN HEAP: Your
name's not Roger.
Your name's Ben.
Who's Roger?
I just-- somebody called Roger.
BEN ARTHUR: You can
absolutely call me--
IMOGEN HEAP: It's
very confusing.
BEN ARTHUR: --Roger, though.
It's completely fine.
IMOGEN HEAP: Oh
well, now we're even.
You have your phone, and
I called the wrong name.
So Ben, Ben Arthur,
your question was--
what was your question?
Oh, the creative process, sorry.
Yeah, so the
creative process was
they really liked a lot
of existing material,
but they needed it
adapted, but they had--
It's a five hour play, and
they wanted a lot of it
to be music underscored,
but they also--
there's kind of three
different types of music.
There's music that
they interact with,
which is when
they're on the stage,
and they're moving
around to the music.
There's the underscore, and
then there's scene changes,
like a wall goes across, and
it's like-- (SINGING) Ha--
and things like that.
And so the underscore
bit is quite a lot
of existing material that
just kind of bumbling away
in the background
that's been adapted,
and stretched, and
added different things,
and lots of high
frequencies taken out
because it kind of gets
in the way of talking.
So I learned a lot about
how to sculpt around
the vocal human voice area.
And then a lot of, yeah,
drones, lots of vocal-- loads
of vocalizations.
There's no lyrics, actually.
There's only one bit
that has a lyric.
BEN ARTHUR: Indeed, that's
from "Hide and and Seek."
IMOGEN HEAP: Of course.
They had to put my
famous song in there.
So that's the one song they
really wanted with a lyric,
and I didn't want to--
it didn't feel right
to have me singing it,
and they did want to have
me singing it anyway,
so I got my friend's
choir to sing it,
and then I kind of added
the vocal layers underneath
and made nice drones.
But most of the time, it was
all about the transitions,
and that was really, really fun.
It really tested my
theory skills to,
like, how do I
get from that key?
How do I modulate from there to
there, and how do I, you know,
do this?
So there's a lot of
existing material.
And very luckily,
over the years I've
been quite vigilant into making
sure that all of the songs
have their stems, and they're
all documented, and kind of
filed quite nicely.
So all of the songs from
"Speak for Yourself" up all
have drums, strings, vocals,
backup vocals, effects, blah,
blah, blah, weird sounds,
arpeggiated things, et cetera,
et cetera.
And then, so I was
lucky enough to be
able to pull that in, and
those ones that I hadn't done,
I've got this awesome
assistant called Alexi,
and he was in my studio back
in Engla-- back in this village
where we live.
And he would be kind of
getting those together and then
dropping them into Dropbox
into Ableton sessions,
where then I was seated in the
theater for about three months.
And just with my little
computer and my little drive
and whatever, and
had my microphone,
and some little toys.
And then I was just there
like that the whole time.
And my only regret is
that I didn't really
get to talk it to anyone
other than, did you like that?
Or could you make that
a bit more like this?
Or could you make it a bit less?
And yeah, so I didn't really get
to talk to the gang very much,
and I was literally there
from 10:00 in the morning
until 11:00 at night, and I
was always-- well, not always,
but I was quite
a lot of the time
the last one in there saying
hi to the security guard.
BEN ARTHUR: And you took all of
this music, something like 100
cues, and created an album?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: Sort of
a cohesive album--
what was that
process like for you?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
so in the theater,
it was really great
because there's
tons of inputs to kind of
react against and be like,
oh, that sound works
beautifully with the light.
Oh, that sound goes beautifully
with the sound effects,
or ah, the pace of that person.
So all of these are
kind of affirmations
that that's working.
That's working.
Keep going, which you
don't get in the studio
when you're all by yourself.
But at the same time, because
it's a big theater system,
and you don't hear a lot
of the detail in the mix,
so it's kind of getting
away with murder in terms
of what I could mix in
the time that I had,
which is 2 and 1/2 hours of
music that, quite a lot of it
done also from scratch.
And so when I finally took
that back into my studio,
it was like, oh my goodness.
I've got so much work to do.
There's a gazillion
pops, and clicks,
and all kinds of things
I had to draw out.
And then just making
it sound lush,
and beautiful, and
layered, and giving it
the attention that I do to
my own records, but to--
well, it's a 78 minute album.
It's like as much as I could
fit on a CD physically possible,
and it's 42 tracks.
And so it goes into
four acts, and they're
like one long piece of music for
20 minutes, another long piece
of music for 20
minutes, but it's
going through 14 or
15 keys, so that's
where the kind of, how do you
get from this key to that key
into 3/4 from 7/8,
duh, duh, duh.
But it's really fun, but
it's a lot of hard work.
And I did most of it
standing up because I also
had a life at that time
in a flat in London,
and so there's a lot
of it just standing up.
But that was quite
good for my posture.
BEN ARTHUR: Excellent.
A personal recommendation.
I've been listening to
the album for a while now.
Walking through the city and
listening to that on headphones
gives you a very weird
magical layer of New York
that-- very surprising.
IMOGEN HEAP: Oh, that's
BEN ARTHUR: Cool.
Because you did a wonderful
job sort of making--
IMOGEN HEAP: Thanks.
BEN ARTHUR: --that feel magical.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: --which.
IMOGEN HEAP: There were certain
sounds that I always kind of
were drawn to.
Kind of the other
kind of secret weapon
I had was I developed
with a company
called Soniccouture my own set
of virtual instruments of all
my favorite sounds in my studio
so that I could basically
take them on the road with me.
So I could have my mbira.
I could have my cello,
like harmonic stuff.
I could have my cocktail kit.
I could have my whirlies.
BEN ARTHUR: Your
marxophone, I read.
IMOGEN HEAP: My marxophone.
BEN ARTHUR: Which is a--
IMOGEN HEAP: My [INAUDIBLE].
BEN ARTHUR: --sort of
socialist trumpet, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
IMOGEN HEAP: No, it's
a bit like an autoharp,
but it has twangs on it.
I don't know what
you're thinking of.
So yeah, a marxophone.
I see, right.
I'm a bit slow today.
Anyway, so cut that bit out.
Yeah, so I have this--
we call it the box of tricks,
which is quite funny because it
ends up being a box of tricks
in a magical theater piece.
And I used all of those
sounds to basically make
things sound like me, so I
would always use the marxophone,
and I'd use the "choir of mes."
I could play "choirs
of me" on my--
I had sampled my voice.
So if anyone wants to make a
song that sounds a bit like me,
you just find the box
of tricks and just
go, la la, a bit of
marxophone, a bit of string,
bit of vocal harmony
things, and some--
BEN ARTHUR: So speaking
of instruments,
I wanted to turn to
the Mi.Mu gloves.
We've got a quick little video
to introduce you all to this
if you haven't seen it
before, and here she goes.
[MUSIC - IMOGEN HEAP, "JUST FOR
NOW"]
IMOGEN HEAP: OK, that was
really not a very good example
because--
BEN ARTHUR: Thank you.
IMOGEN HEAP: What
happened before--
It's not your fault.
I think it was my team who
some reason gave you that.
But basically, yeah, what I'd
done previous to that is I'd
looped my voice by
catching my voice,
and then it would
create a loop, and then
I would catch another loop.
Well, I'd actually
put that aside,
and then I would
catch another loop,
and then I'd put
that aside, and then
I'd catch another loop,
et cetera, et cetera.
And what I'm doing is I'm going,
posture, first up is record.
And when I'm out of that
zone, it goes to play,
or when it goes to
this zone, it plays.
And then it continues to play.
And then I can't
remember exactly
because that was
ages ago, but it's
something like when
I want to pull up
the volume of the
first loop, then
I would use my finger like
this, and I would just
be like, up, down, up,
or just go straight up.
It would be 120, 127 in MIDI
note, but like 100% loudness.
And then if I wanted
to add reverb,
I just used my secret
finger posture,
which basically activates
the reverb fader,
or like the pop in my software.
And it just says
from 0% to 100%.
So if I was like, dong,
you just sound like now.
But if I was over there,
it would be like dooong,
as if I was in a massive cave.
And then yeah, so I
would play bass lines,
or I might play twinkly sounds.
Or it's just things that I
do anyway when I perform.
Previously, you
kind of have to be
kind of a little bit barricaded
by gear if you want to sample
stuff, or you're locked into the
physical nature of whatever box
you're using, and the
gloves are basically
controllers at your fingertips.
And you can just be very
expressive to something
which is quite boring,
actually, in real life.
It's just like, turn up a thing
to 100%, and it's like it,
eh, but you could do
that really expressively,
like yeah or
something like that.
But this is much more like, oh,
she's making her voice bigger,
or she's catching
her voice, and now
she's moving it left
or right, or maybe even
in surround, which I'm
doing on the tour, kind
of moving it around a 3D space.
And then just kind of sampling
my voice, bringing in the coda,
harmonizers so I can
harmonize with my voice.
Sometimes I integrate it
with an IR camera-- well,
they don't make them
anymore, but a connect,
and I would map the stage
into different zones
so I could be like,
when I'm over there,
then make the drums more sparse.
And when I'm back here,
make them more frenetic.
Or when I'm over there,
switch my harmonizer to minor,
or when I'm over here.
Or when I'm in the middle,
take out my harmonizer.
So using the stage
spatially to effect
the kind of bigger parameters in
change in a system like Ableton
or [INAUDIBLE] whatever.
So it's basically like a
mapping device, but how it feels
is you take on the physicality
of something which doesn't
have a physical representation.
It's like a filter or
a bunch of effects.
It doesn't have a thing.
It's not like a bass guitar.
It's like, ah,
that's a bass guitar.
It's like a reverb, so
you become the reverb,
and you become the
mixing desk, and you
become the multiple voices or--
Yeah, the only downside that
I've discovered from it,
other than lots of
programming to kind of get it
so it feels really human, so
you're never even thinking
about, actually, I'm going
to bring in my reverb now.
I'm going to sample my voice.
It just becomes second nature.
I'm going to record my voice,
going to make it a bit bigger.
Now I'm going to add some har--
some delays.
You kind of create a gestural
language the more and more you
use the system
because it, obviously,
has a bit of software between--
they're called Glover--
which you could also
add other inputs.
So you don't have to use
the gloves with Glover.
You can use--
Yeah, you can use connect.
You can use [INAUDIBLE].
You can use an iphone.
You can use Leap Motion.
You can use whatever,
other types of inputs.
And then use them to move around
things in Ableton or whatever.
So the gloves are
essentially just trying
to get away from
this limited space I
felt of trying to add
lots more gear to create
a fluidity or a kind of
spontaneity on the stage.
BEN ARTHUR: Sure, and for
you, now that you've actually
developed these,
do you find when
you perform that
you're in them most
of the time, all of the time?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, I
wear them all the time--
BEN ARTHUR: All the time.
IMOGEN HEAP: --on the stage
because why take them off?
They're quite pretty, and
they don't itch or anything.
They basically have
eight bend sensors.
They've got 1, 2, 2, 2, and 1.
They have lights for
feedback, and you
can program the lights
to do whatever you want.
You might be like, turn
it red when I'm in record,
which you know it's in record,
but it's nice for the audience
to see, oh, it's in record.
It's gone red.
And then it's got a battery.
It's got an IMU so that you
can get your positional data,
and it's got an accelerometer,
so you can be like, drum peaks.
And I do air guitar as
well, which is really fun.
And yeah, so that kind
of combination-- then
you've got your axes, so
you've got your pitch.
You've got yaw, and
you've got roll.
And then you've got
different zones--
backwards, forwards, up, down.
And the combination of that
leads to so many possibilities
because if you have a
keyboard, and you're like,
I'm going to play a
squidgy bass sound.
So you might be like,
dum, dum, dum, dum.
And you want it to go--
woo, woo, wow or something.
You could do that with pressure.
You could make it
slightly harder
if you want it to go, wow.
But if you want it to do
that and change the tone
or something around
it, you would
have to use your other hand,
which is then entirely consumed
by going wow.
And you're suddenly just
playing a three note bass line
with a wow thing,
but you could just
be going, wow like that the
same, but just your whole hand,
and you could move
around the stage and do.
Yeah, so it's not
good for everything.
It's not good if you want
to play some Rachmaninoff
with your fingers, but
you do that on the piano
because that's what
the piano is for.
It's really for all
of the unseen bits,
the bits that don't have
a voice or a physical.
BEN ARTHUR: Nice.
IMOGEN HEAP: But you
do get lost in it.
That's the only thing.
BEN ARTHUR: Interesting.
IMOGEN HEAP: You just--
I close my eyes all the
time, and I'm in the zone.
I'm playing "Hide and Seek."
I'm layering my voice and
bringing in a harmonizer,
and I'm like, god, I
finished this song.
Did I actually look at anyone?
Because it's like
you're playing,
and it fills you because
I have inner ears as well.
I like just to hear the
sound, and I'm just like--
You just get lost because
you don't touch anything
like a machine or whatever.
It just kind of--
it becomes really
like a second skin.
BEN ARTHUR: A
visceral experience.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: Fascinating.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
It's really cool.
BEN ARTHUR: And where in
the development process
are you right now?
Are you licensing it to someone?
Are you looking for
a funding partner?
Are you--
IMOGEN HEAP: Why,
are you offering?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, funny you should ask.
BEN ARTHUR: I was going to
wait till later, but OK.
IMOGEN HEAP: No,
I'll tell you what
we've been doing because
it has been quite hard.
I'm not-- corporate
structures and all that stuff
is not my forte.
So we have a team, and they've
grown over the eight years
since we started developing it
for my own personal fun time
use, which then became we did
some conferences, and things
like this, and one before.
And over time, I've had loads
of interest, tons and tons
of emails that we set
up a company eventually
because it's like, well,
maybe we should make them
instead of just for my
own personal enjoyment
or for my shows.
And so we did start
to develop them,
but that's a huge curve to
have to make it something
that everyone can use,
software that's intuitive,
hardware that's robust,
and cheap enough
to make enough of them.
So we've made like 50
handmade pairs for people
over the years, and now
we are getting much closer
to releasing
something this year,
which just 100 pairs, but
they will be manufactured,
and it will be a lot down--
not that much down in cost,
but maybe in five years time.
If enough people
buy Teslas, they'll
be like 2 quid next year.
So you know, the early adopters
do pay the higher price,
but they get the benefit of
better service and whatever.
BEN ARTHUR: Sure.
IMOGEN HEAP: So yeah, this year
we're going to release them.
We have released the MINI.MU.
If you have a small
child in your life,
you can make your own glove.
It's quite basic,
but it's still fun,
and you can build it
and code it yourself,
and it's called the MINI.MU.
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah, I can't
wait to see a ballet.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, your girl.
BEN ARTHUR: Well, I do--
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: --have
a youngster who
might be interested
in such, but I
can't wait to see a ballet
where the dancers become
the musicians.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: So
whoever out there is
doing that should
do that because it
seems built for a hybrid art.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, you kind of--
because you use your whole body
to move your hand--
you know, you don't just
be like-- he, he, he.
You're like, dah dah.
Even though you might
be just going like that,
you kind of want
to go like that.
You know, it's like
I'm catching the sound.
So forth for the dancer,
they use their whole bodies,
and you could--
I mean for fine detailed
sounds, they're great,
but you could equally
use an infrared camera
or a kind of an array to have
a play space with some dancers.
But combined with
the gloves, you
could get a lot more
detailed and really amazing
timing like you don't
notice any latency at all.
BEN ARTHUR: Neat.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
it's really fun.
BEN ARTHUR: Well, speaking of
broad shifts in technology,
we wanted to talk about
Creative Passport.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: And we have a
brief snippet of a video.
You can see the longer
full video on the YouTube,
but for the moment,
we'll show you this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The Creative
Passport, an identity
in a searchable database
for music makers to upload
and share their
information, everything
you'd like to share about
you as a music maker verified
and in one place.
Map and empower the global
music making community
as you list and link to your
music and sound contributions.
Add unique descriptive data
to your profile and individual
works to increase
discoverability
for brand partnerships, play
listing, syncs, collaborations,
live, or session bookings.
At the same time, enabling
music services to innovate,
benefiting both us
and our audiences,
this is an identity that
belongs to and works for you,
while also connecting all
of your external existing
IDs in one place.
Imagine uploading your
biography only once
but updating simultaneously
across all services.
Sounds good?
Who's going to build it?
You and I, we all are.
Step by step with music
makers and services,
in forums we host
all over the world,
on our ongoing
music and tech tour.
Interested?
Show your support.
Sign up, keep up to date
with the latest developments,
and get involved at
MyceliaForMusic.org.
Let's bring this necessary
missing layer, a music maker
database, to life for the health
of our global music ecosystem.
Because let's face it,
nobody else can do it for us.
The Creative Passport by
music makers for everyone.
[END PLAYBACK]
IMOGEN HEAP: There
we go, so join up.
We don't really have
anything at the moment.
This is more like a kind of
call to action for musicians
to think about their
identity, think
about what that means, think
about ownership of data,
about getting organized
really, about having
a place in the world where you
can say, that is the digital
me.
That's where I, as a
creative self, exists.
Because you know
it's great to have
all these different
services, and they
have their own
identities for you,
or you maybe have a profile
on Twitter, and la, la,
and all these other things.
But where are you?
Like I feel very torn apart.
I feel very like a
big massive tentacle,
and the ocean's just--
I don't have a center like
you're speaking to my center
as a physical thing,
but I don't have that.
And more and more as
we kind of progress
into developments in AI and
discoverability, incubation,
and I really believe
that the future of work
is going to be around
our unique selling points
about how we express who
we are in the digital space
so that our cells
are working 24/7
on our behalf in other words,
perhaps, with our ethos
interfacing with the world.
And so when it
comes down to music,
how do we present ourselves?
We have a major problem
in the music industry
whereby the commercial
music industry didn't adopt
the technology of MP3
and didn't see Napster
as this incredible, amazing
opportunity to go, wow,
this is life changing for
musicians and the industry.
Let's get on this and make
it something really great.
And instead, they kind of went,
let's sweep it under the carpet
and put people in jail.
And really, just people wanted
to share music that they loved,
and so what happened
was that you
had a huge disassociation
from the music and the people
that made it.
Then it just never
managed to catch up,
and the music industry has
been trying to catch up,
and they're basically
firefighting every day
as people try to innovate
on this very crooked kind
of heavy, clunky industry.
So there's thousands
of services,
and I've spoken to
hundreds of them, who
want to build new services
using existing music,
but to reach that point where
they have the permission
to do that to license the
music, it's just not viable.
They have to raise so much
money with VC that it then
only leaves little, tiny scraps
for the musicians in the end
if any, and it's a
very lengthy process.
And I just feel
more than ever we
have an opportunity with
new technologies where
we could create an
open database of works
that the whole world could
come around and create
this kind of Alexandria, this
library of content, whereby
all of the music services,
the labels, the publishers,
the collection societies, who
all have their own databases
at the moment, costing
them huge amounts of money,
that they have to keep
updated and verified
and all that stuff.
And they're all
incomplete, and they all
compete with one another.
BEN ARTHUR: Right
IMOGEN HEAP: But
if that was just--
just get rid of that.
We don't need to have multiple
versions of the same thing,
and all slightly different,
and all slightly bad.
Let's just have-- let's
share into a space
and contribute to that alive
kind of world of music,
and data, and augment
what's already there
into something that can be
tuned in to by all the services
so they don't have to have
that weight on their back,
basically.
BEN ARTHUR: Right,
so speaking of that,
you say on Mycelia that you
see this as a potential portal
for income.
Can you talk about how
blockchain relates to Creative
Passport or doesn't?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, sure.
So for me, I've been in the
music industry 23 years.
It's very, very
hard to know where
your money is at any one time.
We spent about a year trying
to research just the income
for one song, just
one song, and it's
taken a team of seven students
on and off for a year just
to try to get to the bottom
of where does it come from?
What is that radio station?
What is that thing over there?
Why does that not
match up with that?
And that's, for me,
with a team of people
going into the offices at
the PRS and the collection
societies.
Could you explain this?
I don't really understand that,
and we're still only 5% there.
So it's an insane amount
of complication for--
which comes from the physical,
the old day 100 years ago.
You know, how do we pay your
publisher when something
gets played on the radio?
And it's much simpler.
So the Creative
Passport is really just
about us putting our flag in the
sand, musicians at the moment,
verifying each other through
peer-to-peer verification,
like we have a QR code.
You just shine your camera
on someone else's QR code,
and you go, OK, I
verify who you are.
And that is a thing that
then creates a trust network
around all the music makers
across the planet in time,
but we're not
ready for that yet.
We're just doing
a very kind of--
we're mainly just going
around the world doing
this tour, where I do concerts.
I do workshops.
I show off my gloves.
I give con-- I do conferences.
I do Q and A. I
do whatever I can.
And we meet with music
makers and services,
and we talk about
this feature ecosystem
because essentially, if we
had this incredibly rich data
source linked to
the actual content,
linking out to all
of the musicians
who contributed to
those works, then
you can imagine all these
amazing possibilities
of discoveries, and connections,
and offerings of jobs,
and new--
You know, somebody
wants to book somebody
a private concert
because they saw,
they heard something in
Spotify, or Google, or whatever,
YouTube.
And they went oh, why,
I really, really liked
that person's work.
I'm going to try and
book her, and maybe you
do it right from the song.
And you link, or you say,
I love that trumpet player.
I want to put that
trumpet player--
trumpet in my film,
and then they put
the trumpet player.
But if we don't have a
way to kind of go, here
I am, and here are my songs,
we don't have anything
to build from.
We don't have a home.
BEN ARTHUR: Imagine you were
at a large, influential tech
company talking to some very
handsome and smart employees.
How would you convince
them to support you,
and how could they
support Creative Passport?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I think-- we're not ready
for big integration yet.
We need to go kind of and create
a groundswell among musicians
so they kind of own this space
because this is an autonomous
thing we need to do.
We need to convince music makers
to take charge of their data
and to really take their
digital self seriously.
So at the moment, we are
talking with tons of services.
We might have four or five, a
little handful by April or May
when we come in the
tour around here,
and we do more, so to
bring on more music makers.
But we're not ready for that.
It's not like
Myspace or LinkedIn.
It's not like-- it's not ready.
It's just-- imagine
if you owned this.
Imagine if you
owned your identity
and what could grow from that.
Because then if we reach
like 1,000 or 10,000,
what's going to be the
tipping point for someone,
a company, an organization
like Google, to go,
we're going to
integrate our YouTube
service with the
Creative Passport,
and that would be mega, but
we're not ready for that
yet because you don't have
an incentive enough just yet
because we would need to
have hundreds of thousands
before it's of interest.
BEN ARTHUR: Right, so
you need musicians, maybe
some in the audience
and other people
out there in the
YouTube audience,
to come and sort of be
a part of the community
and help shape that
so that you become
a large enough organization
so that you can more--
IMOGEN HEAP: Pull some--
BEN ARTHUR: Yeah,
pull some weight.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
BEN ARTHUR: OK, fascinating.
IMOGEN HEAP: Because yeah,
we have representatives
on our behalf, like labels,
and publishers, and collection
societies, but a lot of us
don't, like so many musicians,
don't have any way to get
even into any industry
because they might
be in Sudan, or they
might be in-- who knows
where they might be.
They have no way to
get onto the ladder.
And if we can try and
reach our handshake across,
or our Mexican wave across
the world, or whatever,
to these musicians,
then we're bringing them
into this truly global
community, music community,
that then hopefully all
the services will start
to think, oh, well
that's actually
really interesting
because now we're
reaching into this market,
and this market, and this.
You know, and that's
their incentive.
But for us, it's
how can we create
a beautiful, healthy,
living kind of ecosystem
from which these services
can grow kind of on our--
that makes sense for us.
And then we're
truly sustainable,
and then we can have centuries
of wonderful, beautiful music
because the musicians
are supported.
BEN ARTHUR: I think we
have a question for you.
AUDIENCE: I think Mycelia
is very interesting.
I'm kind of curious.
So you obviously need the
three majors to be involved.
IMOGEN HEAP: Not yet.
AUDIENCE: You don't think so?
IMOGEN HEAP: No, I don't
think we need them.
No.
AUDIENCE: How does
Merlin feel about it?
IMOGEN HEAP: The thing is, it's
like it's outside of licensing.
This is about your
personal identity.
It's my skill sets.
It's my projects.
It's my interests.
It's my philosophy.
It's my biography.
It's things that aren't
actually, at this moment,
to do with my songs.
They would link into a songs
database, which Mycelia isn't.
Mycelia is like the
vision, the blue sky
imagination of the future,
but the Creative Passport
is a thing.
It's like an app, a trust
anchor for other services
to be able to go, oh, yeah, that
is Imogen Heap because she's
got a Creative
Passport, and she's
been verified by her
peers, blah, blah, blah.
So if you wanted to
go and book a gig,
some promoter could
pretty much trust you
because you've been
verified by your peers,
and you have a good track
record, and that kind of thing.
So at the moment,
where the record ind--
the majors are going
to get interested is
when this database
does start to emerge,
which it is starting to
emerge in places like Sweden.
There's one in Malta.
There's one--
And actually, here
there's going to be
a new one around the
Music Modernization Act,
around the mechanicals,
how they're
going to be paid to
the writers, and that's
something that just passed a
few months ago in Congress.
So they have to build that
in the next two years,
and I'm going, hello,
IBM and Berkeley.
How are you going to do that
without the music makers?
How are you going to
build that without us
being able to add to the
content that you have
around your publishers
because that's
how they're going to build it.
They're going to combine the big
publishers together and create
another database, but it's
only going to be as good
as their combined
databases, and it won't--
The problem with that is
that, whether they're guilty
or they're not, the money that
comes in from the services
will then go to
this body, and then
the money that can't be
distributed, because they don't
know the writers, because
they're too small fry,
and it's too much effort
for them to do it,
will just go back to the
writers that they do have.
They do look after, after four
years or whatever the deal is.
It's probably
something like that.
It will get redistributed
back to the original writers
that they look after, so
the other writers are all
around the world,
and all the smaller
writers won't get that money.
And that's tiny amounts
to these other artists,
but to them it could be like
50 quid, or 100 quid, or 1,000
quid.
So when they create that, we
want the Creative Passport
to be able to enable individual
musicians to be able to author
into and claim a way to kind of
point to this is how to pay me,
or this is my
collection society.
Well, this is actually
me, this missing bit here.
So that we can tidy up
and do the job for them
that they can't afford to do
because it's tiny amounts.
So the majors like the
record side of things,
because they don't have--
yeah, ISRC, and your ISWC
are two codes that you have,
your recording and
your publishing.
There is no shared database
of that, which is crazy.
And so if this does
start to emerge,
that may be where
the majors start
to pile in their
recorded data, and that
might start to flourish and
become this big Alexandria.
Who knows?
If we can kind of make--
if we can find a way
in for the musicians,
and it can grow
further, otherwise it
will just became become
another kind of clearinghouse,
kind of closed space, which
will have all this money put
into it by the public money, but
it won't be further reaching.
It will just be another
closed database,
and that will be a shame.
BEN ARTHUR: So we're running
a little low on time.
IMOGEN HEAP: No.
BEN ARTHUR: I'm
sorry to interrupt.
IMOGEN HEAP: That didn't
answer your question, did it?
Kind of?
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
I mean, it's such
a complicated--
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, it
is very complicated.
AUDIENCE: --space that
it's kind of hard to--
IMOGEN HEAP: Which is
why we need to simplify,
and that's when they're
going to come on board
is when you're
like, when you say,
look, all that
kind of accounting
stuff that you do, and all
that really annoying paperwork,
and that your just
like, oh, god,
I wish I didn't have to do this.
When that disappears because
we have smart contracts,
and payments, and you know--
AUDIENCE: What I'd
say to you, though,
is that that asymmetry
of information
is basically a
competitive advantage
for labels to be able to bargain
with people like Spotify.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And when you
have 70% or 80% of Spotify
as catalog coming
from majors, it
puts them in this
position where they
have to ingest major's data, and
this is where I'm sort of like,
don't you need the
majors onboard?
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, so
that's a good example.
And the thing is
that if you look
at the long term, the majors,
they might hold licenses for--
I think a maximum of 35 years.
AUDIENCE: I mean, 70--
I mean, the Beatles stuff is
about to come out of licensing,
and it was was
from the '50s, so--
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah,
but it's like if you
think of all the new
material, and most--
the trend is big labels hold
large amounts of existing work,
and younger up-and-coming
artists, or people like myself,
own our own works, and
we have small holdings
around our own works.
So how can we make
that really easy
so that people like Spotify
can deal with us directly?
AUDIENCE: So it's a
chicken and egg problem.
IMOGEN HEAP: It is,
yeah, and we need
to be the chicken or the
egg, whichever way we
need to get on with it.
We need to make the
first move, basically.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BEN ARTHUR: We have
another question over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have a
completely different question.
IMOGEN HEAP: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: So I assume
writing and performing
wearing the gloves
kind of causes
you to make different creative
decisions than you would if you
were just using a
regular MIDI controller
with standard encoders.
Are there other
technologies that you
think should be utilized
more or really aren't kind
of getting the attention that
they could that could have
that same potential to
change the way that people
either write and perform
music or experience it?
IMOGEN HEAP: Hmm, thanks.
Interesting question.
I mean, how write
and perform music.
The way-- I really
enjoy the unknown.
Like, oh, there's something
over I haven't tried yet,
or there's an input
there that I've never
had to deal with, like audience
heartbeat info, or something,
or like galvanic skin
response, or something.
Like, what would I do musically
if I knew the audience--
Actually, I'm trying
to develop a thing.
It may never happen because
lots of things don't happen,
but it's just a simple--
It's actually got
a terrible name.
It's called the love glove.
[LAUGHTER]
I know.
It's going to be made
out of shiny material.
No, it's just a
way that I thought
it'd be nice for the
audience to be able to have,
like they could show their love.
Like, I love this bit, instead
of taking camera pictures,
or like clapping at the
end, that I could see,
oh, somebody really
likes that bit.
You know, or oh, they
really, they've got a thing,
and just that
little eye contact.
And I think, when you get
those bits from the audience--
BEN ARTHUR: Isn't that
called a lighter, though?
Just--
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, I suppose so.
Yeah, I suppose that's true.
BEN ARTHUR: It's really only
for the slow songs, though.
I don't know why.
IMOGEN HEAP: Yeah, it
might be something--
I don't know.
I was thinking about, then
I could give back the love.
And I could kind of
pump up the love,
and then they could get
more love in their hand.
And then it would
kind of die down
if they used too much
of it all the time,
so it doesn't get too annoying.
Anyway, I just--
Yeah, it's true.
They could just use a lighter.
You just saved me
like 10,000 pounds.
[LAUGHTER]
I should bring you to my team.
BEN ARTHUR: I'll
Take a check or cash.
Thank you so much for
spending time with us.
Thank you all for
hanging out with us
here at the Talks at Google,
and thanks for the team
for getting all this done.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Imogen Heap.
[APPLAUSE]